two awards at Sundance right for obsidia
in 2010 to spirit awards nominations
right Cassavetes you didn't release the
film for two years due to okay I mean
this really bleeds into like you know
why I wrote a blog recently about self
distribution when we got into Sundance
we were like deer in the headlights yeah
I mean we had not anticipated it and
then we you know we sort of like as I
said in this blog recently you know we
looked up on Google what should we do
and you know there's no handbooks you
know that yet when you get in sundowns
telling you here's here's how to do this
here's what we were like figuring it now
and we sort of thought okay well okay
our film has gone in Sundance oh maybe
it's gonna sell you know like we're
gonna go to Sundance and we're gonna
sell our movie you know and we went to
Sundance it we didn't sell our movie you
know there was I think they were there
it was offers but I were so minuscule
you're like this again I think words
like it's no money and there's gonna be
no like advertising so we just sort of
we ended up the first year after
Sunday's we just went on to the festival
circuit you know and we were talking we
were invited to many festivals around
the world and it was great we had a you
know a great time going tons of
festivals and having a lot of great
experience and meeting lots of wonderful
filmmakers and can lots more wine yeah
you know it was God's of little hors
d'oeuvres which ended really with us the
Independent Spirit Awards you know that
sort of light that was kind of okay like
we've spent a year now doing this that
wasn't one that was Genesis we know
which was very dangerous of bottles I've
never tried to get through one of those
bullets those things aren't we do we
didn't try it um and so and so then we
just you know at that point and i was
still in that old headspace and I you
know this is like being a massive shift
for me this year but i was still in this
headspace of sort of like I didn't want
to be a producer I was kind of like I'm
done with this like I'm just like I'm
done with this movie and with it's like
awful think about it but I was just sort
of like you know I feel like I've done
everything I can and I gotta move on to
the next thing yeah I gotta move on i'm
writing something else and i went to the
sundance screenwriters live with another
project and something I was just like I
just want to focus on new things making
new things and
and so the movie just sort of languished
and it was very lucky then that to be
unlucky that Sundance you know started
this artist services and reached out to
us which was you know their idea for
creating a platform for people to self
distribute them films really in essence
and they reached out to us and said you
know did your film ever get you any sort
of regular distribution do you want out
of this and we're like yeah you know
they said we love your film to one of
the first films that we roll out with us
and we were like this is perfect for us
you know and so through that through
artist services basically they
negotiated a deal with a company called
new video who then distributed our movie
you know digitally and online I learned
so much from this and I you know like we
made so many mistakes and did so many
things you know like in hindsight where
I'm like oh no no no and you know that's
why I'm just like you know my next film
that I plan to shoot this year that were
you know we're developing right now I
mean I'm just like from day one like
even right now I'm planning the
distribution often yeah and it's not the
aim is not to try to sell it to a
distributor like that for me like the
model for that if you're making a movie
like absolutely no stars again like an
original kind of quirky film and that
was you know lots of distributor came
through something like we like your film
we have no idea how to sell you know
like you know that was across the board
will you know it's a great film we have
no idea how to sell it you know and this
is the part where I go like about that
thing about being a producer and taking
responsibility for your work now where
my head is and it just wasn't there then
like for me just making the movie was
like the big thing now I'm like no now I
want to like connect the work with an
audience you know if you take the time
to make a film take the time to build
the audience and to like find them and
get that film out to those people and
the magic of these films I think like
you know lady is not film for everyone
it's never going to be a mainstream
movie it's never going to be like a
multiplex kind of movie and the movie
we're making this year is not that kind
of know you know we're not really
interested in those kinda movies you
know so we want to make something else
ner if somebody came along with it well
no but I mean like I don't like they're
not the movies I go see the movies I
seek out to watch personally you know so
like
making this next one I just go like
again I just want to like create this
very niche thing but take responsibility
for it plan the distribution and launch
it myself you know
you